this video is made possible by nordvpn
now you can get a huge discount on a
two-year plan of nordvpn at nordvpn.com
visualpolitik and you'll get four
additional months free more on this in a
little bit
[Music]
imagine a city with more than 80 million
inhabitants that is the entire
population of germany but concentrated
in an area the size of croatia well such
a city exists it is in china and is
known as the greater bay area although
it's not really a city as such but nine
cities that are very close to each other
many of them will surely ring a bell
especially if you're a visualpolitik
fans why wouldn't you be we're talking
about the place where shenzhen and
guangxiao can be found and where hong
kong and macau were also integrated in
other words is the chinese silicon
valley the place where the creme de la
creme of chinese development is
and now i know what you're going to say
grant you are cheating you started
talking about a mega city and now you're
telling us that actually it's a lot of
other cities close together if we put it
like that grant you could say that all
of china is a mega city and get mad
click points out of it well the truth is
that this is a special case here we are
talking about several cities that are
not only very close together but also
share the same infrastructure shared
subway common bus lanes and even shared
roads china's idea is that residents of
the greater bay area can cross this
metropolis from one end to the other in
just one hour in other words it would be
a new silicon valley but bigger more
modern and in the middle of the most
booming region of the planet so the
question is what's the problem here
apart from me being mad for clickbait by
now i'm sure that some of you are
already in the comments section saying
visual political radar again criticizing
china does it bother you so much that
china is rich and prosperous we don't
have a problem with it anything that
creates new pools of innovation and
prosperity is great for us whether it's
china or vanuatu in fact for those of
you who are xi jinping fans watching
this video we have dozens of videos
where we point out the good things about
china what's more have you been
following us since the beginning you
already know that we've been presenting
the good side of china before it was
fashionable but let's continue with our
story for just now
[Music]
that said the greater bay area is a
great project but the question is what
if it were the chinese communist party
that had the problem let's be clear the
relationship between xi jinping and the
chinese businessman is getting worse and
worse for example here's a clue
jack mars costliest business lesson
china only has one leader then we also
have the ever grande scandal that is
causing beijing several hezeks and these
are just two examples in other words xi
jinping wants to have large and
competitive companies but not so big
that they overshadow him and not so
large is to increase the inequalities in
china which are getting greater and
greater so the question the real
question we're asking today is to what
extent can the greater bay project be a
risk for xi jinping will it increase
regional inequalities in china today
we're going to answer all these
questions so let's get cracking
[Music]
the chinese silicon valley
as everyone knows silicon valley is not
a city or even a state it is an area
encompassing several cities however for
all practical purposes you can say that
silicon valley is a large metropolitan
area it is quite normal for a person to
live in palo alto for example and go to
work every day in the google offices
which are in mountain view and then in
the evenings go to meet their friends in
a bar in cupertino what's more if you
look at silicon valley on google maps it
is almost impossible to tell where one
city ends and the next begins it is all
one big metropolitan area an area where
more than three million people live and
where there is money talent and many
many companies all squished together but
wait a minute because silicon valley is
not the only megapolis in the world for
example in the netherlands they have
what is called the ranstat which is the
area that integrates amsterdam rotterdam
and the hague again if you look at a map
you will see that it's almost impossible
to find the line that separates one city
from the other and we're also talking
about one of the world's greatest
centres of innovation and wealth well
the greater bay area or as we're going
to call it from now on the gba is the
same thing but in china so what's so
special about the gba what do they
produce there well pay attention
the gba has been a crucial region
throughout history its ports have been a
base for foreign trade for china in fact
almost all of their foreign investment
that came to china in the 1990s came to
this area remember this is where hong
kong is which is china's gateway to the
rest of the world to give you an idea
today the gba contributes 12 of china's
gdp if it were a country it would be the
12th largest economic power in the world
that is it would be wretched in spain
australia and mother russia and not
surprisingly this region has the highest
concentration of fortune 500 companies
in the country the gba is home to three
of the 10 most important ports in the
world as you can imagine with the
success that has been seen in the region
it was only a matter of time before the
government put the spotlight on it to
further boost its development stay tuned
china unveils guangdong hong kong macau
greater bay area development plan in
february 2019 the government presented a
development plan for the gba and you may
wonder what is the objective what goal
does it want to achieve well the main
objective is to build infrastructure to
link the nine cities that is a person
can live in guangdong go to work every
day in shenzhen and then go to tai chi
classes and foshan but not only that
china also wants to build a common data
platform for the entire gba what kind of
data are we talking about though well
remember that we are talking about china
a hyper technological dictatorship that
takes data from its citizens with fake
recognition cameras police controls and
all kinds of searches well the idea is
the authorities of all these cities
share the data i know it doesn't sound
very good but remember that china is not
willing to prosper at the cost of losing
control of its citizens but that's a
topic for another video to summarise the
goals of the gba are threefold the first
is that people can travel between their
cities in a maximum of one hour they
also want to prioritize a high quality
of life and finally to boost innovation
and technology in this regard shenzhen
provides the technology and hong kong
provides the money and i know what some
of you are thinking especially of those
of you who are less than fans of xi
jinping who is going to put up the money
are we talking about a 100 public
project well the answer is no check this
out
china's alibaba to lead fund for greater
bay area via startup fund and you will
see okay this is all very well but
where's this money gonna go according to
a study by hsbc bank the main priorities
for now are marketing companies
attracting talent and building offices
and the main sectors where funds would
be invested would be technology finance
and exports and for the moment
everything seems to indicate that the
gba project is working like a charm
go to a leading beijing university talk
to some of the tech graduates and ask
them do they want to move to shanghai or
do they want to move to the greater bay
area you'll see them in shenzhen
managing partner mckinsey gba office in
other words the gba is a fantastic idea
we don't have the slightest problem with
it but remember that we are talking
about china and the priorities of the
chinese communist party are very
different from what we might have at
visualpolitik and this is where the b
side of the story comes into play we're
going to look at that right now but
first it may be that you trust your
government or your internet service
provider but you know what it would be
foolish to trust everyone in the world
cyber criminals exploit all kinds of
vulnerabilities to gain access to your
data doing nothing is not an option you
could end up handing over your data
directly to the wrong person simply put
if you use the internet you need
state-of-the-art vpn encryption and that
is where nordvpn comes in with nordvpn
all of your internet data says staff
behind a wall of next generation
encryption and that's the kind of safety
we should all be thinking about the best
part you'll still be able to surf at
full speed because according to the
independent av test rankings nordvpn is
the fastest vpn in the market and what's
more it has no data limits for example
4k streaming uses a large amount of data
which is why some vpn service providers
actually limit your connection to save
costs but this is not the case with
nordvpn with nordvpn you can enjoy your
favorite live sports without additional
data or bandwidth limitations what more
could you ask for remember the nordvpn
has servers all over the globe meaning
that you can enjoy instant secure access
to hundreds of streaming websites
worldwide and one account lets you
connect up to six devices which means
you get to watch visualpolitik content
from anywhere on the planet even china
and right now you can get a huge
discount on a two-year plan of nordvpn
at nordvpn.com visualpolitik and you'll
get an additional 4 months free it's
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee
the vacated china
[Music]
when we say that china is growing as if
there were no tomorrow we are not really
talking about the whole of china in
reality chinese development has been
concentrated in three very specific
areas the beijing area the shanghai area
and the gba that is where 70 of china's
factories are located however as we move
inland we find regions like gansu which
is the per capita income of countries
like kenya or pakistan take a look at
this map
[Music]
let's be fair these areas are also
growing but the gap between rich china
and not so rich china is widening of
course this doesn't really have to be
bad news in reality china's inequality
stems from the fact that the wealthy
areas are growing at a speed never seen
before but do you remember that china is
a communist country in fact xi jinping's
new slogan is precisely common
prosperity that is to say that it is
only now in 2021 when the entire chinese
communist party has to set work to
reduce these inequalities and they have
every reason to worry
think of it this way let's imagine a man
living in gansu one of the poorest
regions in china when this man compares
himself to another man living in
shenzhen he is likely to feel envious
and in this case there is no censorship
i mean you can prevent him from seeing
news from outside the country there is
for example the great cyber wall of
china that we have talked about in other
videos it might even be a good thing
from the point of view for communist
propaganda for him to feel a certain
envy towards americans or europeans who
have a better standard of living than he
does after all that would justify the
figure of the external enemy which is
always super handy for any dictatorship
however the last thing beijing wants is
to create internal tensions within china
and that explains news like this
china's most ambitious project one belt
one road that's right xi jinping's one
belt one road has a double objective the
first is what we all know to open trade
routes with the entire world the second
is to bring infrastructure and growth to
the poorest areas of china
infrastructure like this
china launches first fully electrified
bullet train in tibet this train would
connect tibet with schwan chan two of
the poorest regions in the country that
will now enjoy one of the most modern
trains in the world in other words
beijing wants to distribute part of the
wealth generated in rich china to the
less wealthy regions whether that will
be enough to bridge the gap it's another
matter at the moment you only have to
look at google maps to see where most of
the roads are no matter how much is
invested in infrastructure in per china
the south east of the country gets the
lion's share
again is this really a problem in
principle it need not be but one thing
is certain if a rich china continues to
grow at the rate it is doing it becomes
too politically powerful so much so that
it could challenge beijing's authority
but hold on a minute because this is not
the only challenge xi jinping may face
the sweet and the sour
[Music]
the slogan of common prosperity goes
beyond closing the gaps between regions
there is also a commitment to bridging
the gap between rich and poor xi jinping
is increasingly distrustful of his
businessmen because he's afraid that
they have too much power or that they
are too big to fail that is companies
that have so much power that they could
affect the whole system recently there
has been the case of evergrande of which
many of you will be familiar it is a
huge chinese real estate company that
has defaulted on millions and millions
of dollars in interest payments
evergrande has even unleashed nightmares
about a possible lehman brothers
movement in the financial market and you
will see well this is a clear example
that xi jinping is right it is a mistake
that private companies have so much
power well it's not entirely true
because the truth is the chinese
government maintains a lot of control
over the economy remember that the main
chinese banks are state-owned in fact
everything indicates that xi jinping
wants to increase the state control
check this out
the implementation of all these
anti-monopoly regulations is absolutely
necessary to improve the socialist
market economy and promote common
prosperity xi jinping common prosperity
is a very clear objective that xi
jinping has repeated on several
occasions in which he implies that
technology companies and their
millionaire entrepreneurs are seen as an
alternative to political and social
power in china attacking the government
and this is why we see regulations on
companies such as the case of alibaba or
even measures such as limiting the hours
a chinese child can play video games
from the big gaming companies proving
once again that everyone in china must
play under the rules of the communist
party however not everything is black
and white because the president also
understands that he has to support his
businessman so check this out
she plans new stock exchange in china to
boost small businesses that is also
right china plans to establish a new
stock exchange in beijing in order to
raise capital and boost small businesses
while we have seen that the government
prefers to finance its state-owned
companies it knows that it must go
hand-in-hand with private companies but
what does all this have to do with the
gba well a lot we are talking about an
area that is already highly developed
but still has a lot of potential it
makes perfect sense that beijing wants
to boost it with infrastructure it could
easily become a new silicon valley but
don't forget that the original silicon
valley also has enormous political
influence so now the question is over to
you how much power is xi jinping willing
to sacrifice in order to boost gross in
this area do you think the chinese
communist party will ever trust the gba
entrepreneurs or will they try to find
some other way to control them you can
leave your answers in the comments below
and as always don't forget that here at
visual politics we release new videos
every week so subscribe to the channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of these
videos if you like this video and why
wouldn't you like it so we can see that
take care and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you